i saw this today and it's kind of
surprising to me i mean i didn't realize
josh mccown was so coveted not only did
the eagles offer him a couple million
fully guaranteed to come out of
retirement but they're giving him
fridays off so he can fly back to
charlotte to coach high school football
i mean
fridays are for i mean unless they're
going to reconfigure their preparation
calendar friday's still a fairly
important day chris and i mean you're
either with the team or you're not what
did mike mack say a week and a half ago
you're all in or you're all out and and
i love josh mccown but
the idea that he's going to disappear to
go coach high school football i i just i
i look hey good for you if you can
negotiate that but i don't know
as a football team why that's something
you'd want to give in on i i'm shocked i
really am i i don't know what even to
say now i mean josh mccann i understand
he doesn't need a lot of reps he proved
that just last week going in going 17
for 24 192 yards and two touchdowns and
he's been at home coaching you know kids
and playing with his own family and
doing all those type of things to where
but i still i am very surprised by this
one i'm actually surprised for josh
mccown that he would even want to do
this i understand he's made commitments
but you know he got a new commitment and
what are they paying him mike 2 million
dollars 2.5 something like that right so
that that that kind of wins the battle
as far as ooh which commitment should i
go more with and i am shocked by the
philadelphia eagles wanting to do this
they're all leaving themselves open for
if carson wentz gets hurt and misses a
few series or misses a game and josh
mccown throws an interception okay let's
just say carson wentz yo there goes
joshua county went to practice or went
to the team high school game in carolina
now it's carson wentz he throws he get
hurts his ankle in a game and josh
mccown's got to come in and he throws
two interceptions oh my gosh i mean i'm
telling you they're going to get crapped
on philly and phil i've got about how
the eagles fans are hey if this guy's
just all in if he was here on friday it
wouldn't be an issue
and and listen i i remember when brandon
marshall was playing for the bears and
he was flying back and forth to new york
on his off day to do inside the nfl and
and i i look what if you've got you know
injury and you need to you should be
getting treatment that day and said
there's always something if you're all
in with your job your only job your main
job your football job there's always
something you can be doing and to
disappear to go do something else um i i
just listen and it's hard for me to say
that because i like josh mccown but i
think we got to be fair to this story
it's a surprise and and what's he doing
the rest of the week when he otherwise
should be in his playbook and watching
film is he is he distracted by this high
school team i mean you got to do one or
the other you could have done espn and
high school football that's fine if
you're going to play one more year of
nfl football um i m maybe you got to set
aside the high school football i think
so i'm mike i'm 100 with i like josh
mccown a lot and damn i respect the
eagles about as much as any team and all
the football with what the way they run
their team and organization i really do
but i'm with you i i don't like this i
don't especially for a super bowl team
uh i really don't and this is the last
point i'll say about it
friday is one of the few day it's the
only day of the week the backup gets
reps you don't get reps on wednesday and
thursday friday practices in the nfl are
usually a day where the backup gets to
come in and get a few reps in the red
zone and then gets to run his own
two-minute drill at the end of practice
and do things like that to where you get
some semblance of okay this is a little
bit of a a game situation and he's gonna
miss that and i know he's been playing a
long time but i just still think it's
risky and i don't like it up for for
either side and i feel like the eagles
were willing to agree to it because they
were so desperate with nick foles gone
to have somebody they felt good about if
carson wentz gets injured he's their
carson wentz insurance policy and i have
a feeling that if wentz suffers a
serious injury and i don't want to jinx
him by saying this but too late for that
now early in the year while high school
football is still happening the friday
is gonna go away if mccown becomes the
guy right for now they're willing to do
it because really hey we don't need
until december anyway sure i mean that's
when once gets hurt go ahead do your
thing september october november and
then you're all in when when we are most
concerned that our starting quarterback
is going to be gone so it's still
unusual and and i i you know we talk
about this all the time hey if this guy
did it he'd be criticized if that guy
did it he'd be criticized most other
players in the nfl if they did this
they'd be criticized and i don't mean to
be critical of josh mccown it's just odd
to me that the eagles would agree to it
there's nothing wrong with josh mccown i
guess wanting to do it if the team lets
you do it i don't know why the team
would let you do it and the bigger
picture is i don't know why you would
want to do it if you truly are all in
with your nfl team 100 and i say that
and josh we love you but we got to say
it we got to do our job and our job is
to call these things as we see them he
he he understands i ain't i doubt he's
watching us but he understands that yeah
yeah but he's a he's an old school guy
too to where yeah i am shocked that he
wanted to do it and i'm telling you i
mean i just you know the i'm with you on
all the things you just said the
philadelphia eagles i mean you know doug
peterson howie roseman ownership uh
jeffrey lurie of course i mean they're
top notch the moves they have made to
embolden their football team make them
relevant every year has just been as
good as anybody we've seen in football
not named the new england patriots and
uh i am i'm just i'm i'm like you i'm a
little surprised they're they're in this
boat
what happens when other guys want friday
or saturday off i mean really you know
you're setting a precedent that uh
whether you're negotiating with the team
and you're you're a free agent or you're
renegotiating your contract
are other guys going to make these
requests and they're going to have to
say well it doesn't count for you
accounts for them we'll do it for them
we're not doing it for you yeah and it
just it creates an awkward situation but
i think it underscores chris bottom line
how desperate the eagles are to have
someone they feel good about in position
to take over for carson wentz and they
don't feel good enough about nate
sutfield or thurston howell iii thornton
mellon clayton thorson one of those
three is the right name of the guy who's
destined to be number three on the death
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports